実はその中の高校3年生の宮坂ないです
今日は牛が時尚年間体験から考えた皆さんに大切にしてほしいと思うこと時間できます
か
私は中学3年生の頃 glc という数に入りました
グローバルリーダーズコスグローバルな人材を育成するクラスです
私はそこで様々な社会問題について学ぶことができました
なんか多く聞いた言葉が多様性です
私が疑問を抱いたのはこの多様性の具体例としてなった
バリアフリーについてです日本はバリアフリー生深刻である
本当にそうでしょうか
確かに駅にエレベーターが歩くとか多く展示向いてるところにあり
舗装された道路も多く最近ではスロープがあるミスも多く見受けられます
しかし実際はバスのの料理には分亭主の方が降りてきて
スロープをかけないといけない0者の乗り降りも
駅遺産はつかないといけないため時間もかかったりすることが多いです
バリアフリーが進んでいるからといって本当にすべての人に対して住みやすい空間が
提供されているでしょうか
私はすべての人がもっと心地よく住める環境を作っていくには性的なバリアフリーのみ
でなく心のバリアフリーが必要だと考えています
そしてその心の場合等フリーに必要になってくるなが人と人との繋がりだと考えてい
ます
ではそもそもになぜ私はこんなにバリアフリーに対して疑問を抱いたのか皆さんの時間
を頂いてまで通して人と人とのつながりが心のバリアフリーを作り出し
社会をより良くするとかかるのかそれは私が一緒のマイノリティーだからです
私の母親は死ん対象会社で阪神もいいもあり
生徒車椅子が生活しじんです
20代の頃にはセラと病気もあり今母の体の中で正常な部分は
上半身の右側だけだといいます
私はそんな母を普通の母親だと思って過ごしてきました
しかし版のような障害をもって出産するケースは珍しく
はぁ私を生んだ時点で日本で7例目だったそので
決して
私はマジョリティであると言えないと思います
て私は自分がマイノリティーであると規制切ったのかそこにも周りとのつながりが豪華
というふうに思います
私は小学校に上がるまで歩けない母親を持つことになんの違和感も感じていませんでし
た
それが私にとって当たり前だったからです
青谷が多く集まりがちな保護者会に父親が来る
学芸課に母親が車椅子でくる
私の母親が障害者であるという事実は学校では周知のこととなってきました
ん
そのうち私はクラスメートや他模倣者の方
先生方から褒められるようになりましたん
しっかりしてて偉いねいつもがんばってお母さん支えてて偉いねこれからも支えてあげ
てね
当時の憐れみの言葉をもらうようになりました
できないことがを入れねかわいそう遺伝しなくて良かったね意外な言葉をもらうことも
ありました
かわいそなくアピールしているいい子だと思われたいんでしょ
私は自分のことをかわいそうだともがんばっていると思ったことはありませんでした
歩けない母親を持つことは別にぷ子にとっては普通のことだったし障害者の母親は他の
健常者のお母さんだとと同じように見えていたからです
それでもそういった言葉をもらうしに自分が一種のマイノリティであるということを
自覚してきました
そしてそれが決定的になったのは中学に上がっていくんですね
私の母親は車いすを使って
電車で通勤していました部活帰りに偶然ハ隣り合わせたことがありました
混んでいたので母親が得ることだけ確認して離れて立っていた時に周りに座っている
アン前に座っている方が
母に届かない音量で心ないことを話しているのを聞いたとき
自分の母親が差別対象だということを自覚し自分がその娘であるということを痛感し
ました
それから私はハート障害についてたくさん話すようになりました
青山囲むことニュースについて思うこと社会について思うこと実際その日にあったこと
差別偏見ハワイに気づかされることもあれば全く共感し合えないことも多くありました
ハート障害について話すようになって感じたことはあははが
経験に基づいた諦めを持っているということです
形状者の人にはどうせわからない
障害者は1周差別対象だ
ここが私が母と最も大きく意見が食い違って店です
私は表会社等健常者は借りられないかも知れませんそれでも分かり合おうとすることが
できると思っています
なぜならまだ息にうお互いに配慮しあう余地があると考えているからです
バスデイ者の霊をまたゲートパスの場合
乗り込み口から遠くに止めてしまうことでスロープが届かなくなりもう一度バスを停車
させなくてはいけなくなったり停車の場合ホームで車椅子の方にもっていただく場合に
線路に対して
制度の向きに車椅子を取れてしまって
万が一ブレーキが外れたときにその音制度の方に行ってしまうような危ない状況が
作り出されていたりなど
津美が原因ではなく人の行いが原因で妻がもっとかかってしまったり危ない状況を
作り出してしまったりするケースを見ることがあります
つべの改良ではなく人の気配りで変わることはたくさんあるんです
顧客の場にいるときに別々に全く関係のない個人としてその場に存在するのではなく
周りに目を向け9人だとしてもお互いにつながりあり考えなくかも使うことが心の
バリアフリーとなり社会を変えていくと私は考えています
それで昔国ディスアドバンテージを持つマイノリティを完全に受け入れることは難しい
かもしれません
それでも私はこれのバリアフリーが社会のマイノリティいう経理に影響を及ぼすという
こともの明かりにしました
それが高校1年生の頃に体験したカムの留学です
私がいていたバンクーバーで印象に残っていたのは歩道をすごい速さで走っている車
いすな方でした
そういった方々のヒットにバンクーバーでは
障害を持っている方たちがいい意味でサポートされている感がなく周りの人たちもそれ
を普通に受け入れていました
確かに国民性もあるのかもしれません
しかし私はそこで心のバリアフリーが神道 c マジョリティーとま nit が
よぞ日回数かよいることができました
例えば今後車椅子の方が税研乗り降りできるようなスロープが付いたパスが改良される
としますそれ
な場所が実際に街中を走るとして
しかしまだそのスロープがの料理に時間がかかるとしますそこでもありの思っている人
が身を守るのではなくイライラした気持ちでそれを見ていたら誰が過ごしやすい環境が
そこにあるでしょうか
確かにその装置で物理的なバリアフリーは公表します
しかし本当にすべての人が住みやすいコミュニティがそれでできたと思いますか
いくら物理的なバリアフリーが進んでも心のバリアフリーガー
いくら物理的なバリアフリーが進んでも心のバリアフリーが浸透しなくては
平等な社会の実現は可能です
私は街中で障害者の人見かけたら必ず大丈夫ですかと声をかけてだすけをすることが心
のバリアフリーだとしているのではありません
一人が周りに気を配り
繋がり合うことで
同じ空間にいる人が少しだけでも周りに気を配り
互いにつながりあって考えな空間を作る事を心のバリアフリー閉じちゃうよんでいます
停車に乗っているとケースも他の一旦顔を上げて周りを見てみる
電車の入り口付近に立っているならその手すりを支えたい人が使えなくなっていないか
確認してみるそういった小さい
音がそう
弊社に乗ってる時スマホから一旦顔を上げてみる
入り口付近に立っているならスロープを使いたい人が使えなくなっているか確認して
みる
そういった細かい小さなことが
停車に乗っている時
停車に乗っている時たスマホから顔を上げてみる
入り口付近に立っているなら付
スロープ
電車に乗っている時言ったその方から顔を上げてみる
入り口付近に立っているのはスロープを必要としていたが使えなくなっていないか確認
してみるそういった簡単なことが周りに気を配り
つながりになり心の針を振りを生み出していきます私たちはせっかくバリアフリーが
進んで社会に生きる
ことができていますジェリー d とも祈り t お互いが歩み寄り
住みやすい社会をつくっていくために
人と人とのつながりが生み出す心のバリアフリーに目を向けてみるべきではない
でしょうか
ご静聴ありがとうございました